what was kind of your breaking point
where you kind of realized like okay
i'm i'm i'm just gonna do my thing um
again i i i can't say it wasn't a
breaking point i just said like
days i'll just show up like man all
right bet you know something that over
time
has been building yeah that you've been
thinking about doing for a while well
when i came here oh this is his show
right this is his show i can't really
again this is his show yeah wrong man
make grown man moves that's what you
want but
i'm also a man and i say whatever i want
to say on my like on my podcast which
you see cutting weight better
shout out to the weight cutters and
babies um they uh on my podcast it's
like
put like this i don't like weak dudes
around me right so if we if this any
negative
like like to uh negativity in my podcast
circle
uh cutting away podcast we'll address it
you know with you how you feeling today
like shout out to my guy justin like yo
and my guy ev and
all right lola behind the scenes like we
have like a great
foundation and i was like bro if you if
you if you know
justin and i we talked before the
podcast because again you know he's
still over there on that side and
i was like bro if you feel any kind of
way we have real discussions
i was like bro but i don't like weak
dudes around me and if any of you are
snakes and stuff like that lose my
number
you know he's like yeah like bro he know
i'm he know how i am he know
what i put up with and i tolerate i
don't tolerate disrespect
and um you felt disrespected at times
well behind the scenes a little bit
because i'm like bro
you know i don't really want to go into
details but yeah but that but i also
that's how professional i am right i can
literally get on the show
and turn it on some people can't you
know yeah i think with the regiment you
guys were doing too
it it there has to i mean not just
obviously you guys are doing three a
week
yeah that's another thing when i got
fired not only did they laugh
then he talked about like podcasting is
hard you know three times a week that
can be rough on i brought my grinder you
know i mean i have [__]
like spoon fed from me right you know
everyone everyone know like how hard i
work i ain't gotta really
you know speak on my record but you know
jeff garland found me at open mics brian
shout out to jeff garland legend i love
[__] jeff that's my guy but again he
found me at open mics
and i'm the guy who come back from the
road and still go to open mics and even
when it's podcasting going on like you
know brian kelly everybody know like how
hard i was